j moins un avant le spectacle à
l'auditorium
cette fois ça y est les enfants de
l'école paul langevin entre dans la cour
des grands ambiance détente à l'heure du
déjeuner avant un dernier après midi de
travail pour les artistes en herbe
ça ne sera pas de trop bah oui je pense
qu il ya un champ parfois j'en leers
déjà verse de l'eau chaude et je vais
essayer de le travailler
c'est ce soir et là en plus encore un
peu pâle fois les dans les groupes des
fois je me trouve
en découvrant la salle où ils vont jouer
les enfants prennent vite conscience de
ce qui les attend
à partir de maintenant on est aux
répétitions
c'est à dire que vous êtes tous acteurs
les maîtresses et les maîtres sont
acteurs aussi ils vont quand même
derrière vous offert la boxe c'est vous
qui vous prenez rhin
c'est la première fois que le groupe
répète sur le plateau dans les décors du
spectacle pour la première fois aussi
les enfants travaillent avec leurs
fresques des élèves de l'école
supérieure de musique
dès les premières notes les apprentis
chanteurs semblent tellement
impressionnés qu'ils en oublient les
consignes d'ismaël le metteur en scène
[Musique]
est ce que j'ai à dire mais pas écoutés
quand tu montes sur le fauteuil est ce
qu'il est monté sur un fauteuil et voter
sur fauteuil pop depuis les coulisses
dominique la directrice de l'école
observe ce qui se passe sur la scène un
peu inquiète c'est difficile ce qui se
passe pas bien il écoute pas toujours
mon faux savants java mais peut mieux
faire apparemment
[Musique]
c'est bien ça la musique je stresse et
vu que pas assez de 20 spectacles donc
ça fasse vite et on a peur de se tromper
en fait
est ce que pour vous c'est exactement
pareil comme eux et on leur dit qu'on a
aussi on a fait même appréhension qu'on
dit qu'on veut et ne doivent pas
s'inquiéter que on comprend très bien
que ça ça devrait bien se passer pour
eux et pour nous pour ça ismaël va
devoir remobiliser ses troupes
j'ai la moitié des groupes qui chantent
pas vous n'êtes pas là il est là parce
que vous êtes obligés d'être là mais
vous n'êtes pas là non j'espère que pour
le spectacle
vous avez mettre la patate que l'a fait
juste déprimant demain vous assurez
message aussi le lendemain les enfants
arrivent survolté dans les loges où il
faut bien essayer de se concentrer comme
on peut dans la salle les rangées de
fauteuils se remplissent à vue d'oeil et
à quelques minutes d'entrer en scène un
classique c'est le stress qui gagne
romane pauline et michael mais c'est
normal
c'est normal c'est paniquez pas couché
reeves ou quand il
ça va passer très vite la suite on la
connaît
un spectacle sans fausse note beaucoup
d'émotion sur scène comme dans la salle
et pour les enfants la même envie
revenir très vite à l'opéra
[Musique]